it was a brazen attack in broad daylight
last monday on the streets of this
pro-russian breakaway republic three men
fire rocket-propelled grenades at
transnistria's state security office
russia and ukraine accused each other
and even before we know the truth it's
already a troubling hint of where this
conflict could go next how it could
spiral
from the moldovan hills above
transnistria is a relic of a conflict
frozen for 30 years
the soldiers on the unofficial border
into this land of limbo are russian
it's a place that has all the signs of
statehood it's got its own borders its
own government its own military and its
own currency and yet it is a place
that's recognized by no country anywhere
in the world
inside lenin still stands and the hammer
and sickle is still the symbol of soviet
greatness
and here's the concern ukraine's key
black sea port of odessa is just a
hundred kilometers away
the russians have said quite openly that
they want a land bridge between their
occupation in ukraine's east and their
outpost here far to the west
and among the people here while there is
no desire for conflict we found the
sympathies with russia we're not afraid
we
30 years live in peace with russian
soldiers
30 years ago
we have
we have war with moldavian we not want
to
seem to we want to peace with moldavian
with ukraine
there are some suggestions from moscow
that that maybe the russian military
will move west and maybe try and come to
transnistria what do you think of that
yes
and would that be good for you
yeah
and why is that
[Music]
good nobody wants
any kind of military actions
to take place
in our republic
but this goes well beyond the possible
russian annexation of transnistria of
course everybody is very worried no
question about that listen to the
assessment of the man who was moldova's
deputy prime minister until last
november
our you know future
as an independent state does depend to a
great degree on how successful ukraine
is in fighting for its independence in
uh in resisting and ultimately surviving
as an independent state
well that's fascinating you're
effectively saying your future rests on
ukrainian success over russia on
ukrainian on ukraine's ability to resist
on ukraine's ability to stand firm
yes
moldova is a neutral nation with no army
no protection from nato it's not a
member of the eu and it's reliant for
almost all its energy on this power
station inside transnistria
the vulnerability is clear now a series
of mysterious attacks and russia's form
for creating provocations in a region so
volatile the focus is now on
transnistria
mark stone sky news in moldova